feeling those facts the thing that i
wonder about with drake bell is if you
get famous
when you're 15 and your audience is 15
is it possible there's something that
happens in your brain that makes you
stuck
no no way all these mickey mouse kids
seem like they got matters all
off they got issues but they're not
[ __ ] kids timberlake you can't be
making
a pedophile by being famous at 15.
there's no no he was hitting you though
does that brain stay at 15.
like something happens you're not
necessarily always a pedophile
but you like stay at that age i do
call it culkin kind of off no like the
vampire [ __ ] like you know how like if
you have a vampire bites you whatever
age you are you stay that age
i do think that that is the case with
like molestation
like michael jackson and being famous
not even famous
in the room with adults but maybe you
could argue like fame
is like a version of molestation i think
so
yeah like they're they're abused because
what is you get your innocent stripped
yeah [ __ ] awesome twins they look
like [ __ ] gremlins but just because
you stay young don't mean it means you
want to [ __ ] young people that's the
point
but he was just talking to this 15 year
old he was just texting you know i did
an episode of a tv show with that guy
really there was a show called safe word
where celebrities were like trying to
dare each other to do [ __ ] oh no
safe words oh no yeah wow yeah
oh no i'm saying he was on it but that
[ __ ] stayed using his safe word
which you know
i get it you would think you would do
that for your victims holy [ __ ]
i got the whole audience to boom really
you wouldn't do [ __ ] the whole point is
like you're just daring each other
yeah to do these crazy things and tweet
these crazy you gotta post that video
son
mtv cut it because obviously they don't
know how to be funny but i was just in
like the panel and they would just have
us there to make comments
and when he i was like yo everybody boo
this [ __ ] and the whole audience
started booing him it was great
he's like you gotta get that in
retrospect we should air it the guy
deserves it
yeah you gotta get that clip yeah you
gotta hit it did you get any like uh
weird vibes from i was no i i just
thought he was like
he was an awkward looking guy and i was
like oh he was probably like the [ __ ]
when he was younger and now it's
probably a tough adjustment because
you're not what exactly was he doing so
the crime is that he was
messaging a 15 year old and they they
haven't released the messages but they
were allegedly
sexual in nature oh yeah so he's
sexually talking to
these kids if you're doing that on texts
you've done crazy [ __ ]
and his ex accused him of abuse and all
sorts of crazy [ __ ] apparently she
moved in with him when she was like 17
or something like that oh yeah yeah
the guy's got a rap sheet of like issues
did you start abusing her when she
turned 18
maybe i don't know so maybe then it's
okay
well i was saying like
he was done
you